[Music]
don't say robust roasts it makes me
angry you try I know but don't say
robust roasted robust or I can't stand
when people don't have to say - make
sure I emphasize the words otherwise
mess it up robust rows a robust roast
that Christmas fun is a robust roast
thank you that's what I say to start a
conversation Starbucks I know hey how
you doing good morning how about that
Christmas went robust roast am i right
first of all there are a couple things
that are bothering me about it one is
it's brimming it's almost about and then
you're you're you you're like I'm like a
scientist where you're getting the right
amount of almond milk and you're
stirring it and then you turn them in
you go it's a row this is like liquid
gold it's a robust roast and you made it
look so good I taste it and it tastes
good but don't it's nice though it's
nice it's no big brown roast but it's
nice it's not a big brown the ground
almost when I take the rifle coffee Oh
No
JT my boys should be in my show they
came to my she didn't go out there I
didn't have time because I was their
offices are crazy their offices I hear
they're off in Utah yeah man Utah why
yeah
what you looking pretty cute this
morning maybe you're looking at me like
the sweater where'd you get that it's
not a sweatshirt it's sweater from roots
from when it's on sale from roots you
know Phil yeah well he looks snuggly is
wow it is now you look snugly now what
do you mean oh no I do get it's Turkey
what why turkey I'm not a you look at me
like I'm a piece of Turkey bro nah bro
you look super snugly yeah I'm snugly
but don't say slightly old warm and snug
that's disconcerting to me because
you're a giant man no don't cuddle me I
don't want you to follow me I can't move
mm-hmm
that's been oh no you can't come in here
just in a snuggle sweatshirt the costs
nothing you do I know we're cold and you
told ya I was called I had I drank hot
mulled T's
and sat by the fire with blankets draped
over my shoulders I read a good hard
covered novel ah [ __ ] you
why I'm sure it one
I had to see gun I didn't ah ma ma ma ma
can I have some more champagne and I
have more mold mold wat mulled wine or
perhaps some multi and then thank you
mama thank you for having me I said Papa
Papa can I lose less the pecan pie papa
a small piece of pecan pie and then my
mother would come over and tuck me in
and all your major yes I was reading a
hardcover was reading this is e dick
this Moby Dick is ravishing it's really
fantastic
laughing papa Thank You papa thank you
mama I was a nut I don't know sometimes
I have to feel like I'm an aristocrat in
my family's massive home in Park City
yeah cuz I'm gonna inherit it someday
you fell yeah let's kill him guess who's
gonna inherit it yeah I'm gonna turn my
parents against my sister yes so get it
so I get the whole house yeah and then
we so hard either yep time to start the
room yeah we start a cold time to start
the room or miss right let's sort of
cult like Manson that's all hey pops
sorry that Kathleen keeps talking bad
about you just know that I got your back
what my daughter mm-hmm or next time
your sister Divis out the pie you say
dad don't eat that I saw him messing
with it like let me try this isn't you
potential poison it that's a good idea
route [ __ ] you're out [ __ ] well my my
brother is my brother-in-law you know
who manages my money smart guy there's
one of the smartest guys he goes like
this bing crosby's yeah and he's also
real good with business like the way you
are like he knows business yeah and me
I'm you know retired at 40 me I'm not
the best about numbers and details and
he goes I go looks like we're gonna
inherit this house and he goes yeah
looks like we are and somehow I'm gonna
figure out a way to get it out of your
little paws yeah he can figure [ __ ]
Albright we got your behind this line
what huh okay I trust everybody we got
you man I'll brought out of times your
money bye
hey guys shine this way huh how come the
L'Occitane see your being
I'm cold out here then he came knock in
an old brand brand store yep I can't
have you in there how come how come cuz
you're a nuisance
cuz I'm old now by that time I'm gonna
sweat I let you in
I'll have den I don't think anyone could
turn you down their sweater thanks buddy
it's pretty it's pretty good now hold on
hold on yeah the sweater like that want
a Snuggie oh yeah no one's gonna want to
[ __ ] you're wearing that thing
well like I think you would get in here
and your wife fried told you to wear it
right yeah that's because she told me I
was snuggling here she don't want anyone
to look at you sexually it's not a
sexual swell no no no that's like that's
like that's like sit on my lap and I'll
and I'll tell you it what did tell me
what you want for Christmas s like hey
girls gather around I'm gonna drop some
knowledge about my favorite books on you
I'm gonna teach you I'm a read a story
I'm gonna read poetry out of a hardcover
novel with I'm gonna drop the OB dick
quotes and my testosterone is very very
low yeah I need TRT sweatshirt well I
had a long talk with my boy Justin DS
who's one of I guess Phil Heath trainers
bodybuilder trainer nutritionist and
before you're gone yeah before you go on
before you tell the story yeah you got
to be careful bodybuilders nutritionist
dietician whoa now go 100 go what I'm
saying is his his his girl beautiful his
wife who is filled with no Justin DS
whole word his wife is gorgeous and
she's number four in Miss Olympia
she's stand with what competition though
mister Miss Olympia oh cool yeah so I
said just took her balls down the back
geez look she actually looks insanely
feminine which one you like much like if
I had a wig on in a vagina like you know
his wife and I said it's straight up - I
go you cuz most women look so man ask oh
you are a beautiful green about jamming
and she's be judge this yes along do the
homies work I'm not at all but anyway
more importantly I cut right to the
chase of him what's the game I cut right
to the chase I go
her last name is DS she was fourth and
he's nuts oh I'm sorry I can't remember
her name
wait it was [ __ ] wait I peed yes now
bodybuilder right you see something else
mr. treeger figure they use body figure
competitor folds yet stiff was different
I thought you're talking about the
bakery no those girls are that black
girl dominate yeah yeah Heather DS yeah
yeah yeah there she is she's something
else she's she's all she's all girl
either way I cut right to the chase with
mr. just and I went I went brother I go
yeah there she is I mean she's look at
her I'm not gonna teeny clearly check
look never go the one which is in the
weight room with a barbell I mean she's
[ __ ] bomb in yeah see I thought it
was armed sourcing of the wig
you know careful cuz we say Olympia
right I'm thinking big-time no and she
said he said he said she's about as
she's about as naturally when he met her
she was about as naturally musculars
again oh really
no I cut to the chase to him I go now
I'm 50-year old man I want to talk to
you right now about TRT I want to talk
to you about testosterone and he those
guys know their [ __ ] zoasty reduce yeah
they know their stuff they know about
all of it they know it's like temas the
other mass their their cameras their
[ __ ] chemist
JT is a different story but kick you I
went ahead and picked his brain and that
guillotine don't be surprised
do not [ __ ] be surprised him in a
couple years my skin's looking a hotdog
red and and I got another hair
transplant all right you know she's not
natural right I don't think any of them
are completely natural
I mean body pillars are very open about
that stuff no they're not well well
maybe it depends on they can't be
response or stuff like yeah like G&C
look like yeah Ronnie Coleman I think
yeah yeah she shreds up at during
competition why the waitress can be good
on there but but talking to him about
steroids and TRT is I going to the Apple
store and them telling you how good
Apple phones are yeah do you get that I
do which is super Pro TRT steroids well
no I just if I'm gonna ever do it I'm
going to I'm going to a dude who's been
trained you know you're the doctor you
got a dog he said that you don't want to
go to them cuz that's like going to
someone you know I'm saying I don't know
that believe your song foo is the answer
to all your prayers
we walk in a kung-fu shop I tell you
concludes the best job you walk in his
steroid shot yeah my steroid shop I mean
engage in conversation she yeah well he
he was what I what I mean is anyone
no one's ever died from steroids bro no
I can't prove it no he's ever done
no no he's highly he's really
intelligent about it like mom he knew
the the steroids is thick and the heart
muscles I mean he gets deep into it he's
a very smart guy but what was
interesting was that I'm saying if I
want to put on 10 pounds of muscle if I
want to just show up a little Jack I'm
going to that guy
so and then did he explain this so TRT
in steroids is completely different and
they see other things charities not
gonna put my correct he said to me he
goes it's not gonna do the work for you
you can get on testosterone he goes he's
got guys who get on testosterone would
nothing's happening because you still
got a workout like a mother for no no
nobody but even if you were to get on
trt and workout it's like I can get you
jack yeah that's not right right you got
to take like you'd have to whatever back
you and workout like like they work out
like a lot of it just go faster you can
recover faster you were faster and you
can get by with eating shitty and stuff
like that by the way media people's a
lot of Beatle thing do they kill entity
they're just let raising your levels to
a natural human level yes that we had a
fifty year old it's you just not
supposed to be that high but it's
natural for human being highest but he
wants you to be like Vitor Belfort he
said he would do what you would do is
you'd bring in your testosterone to like
between 1000 and 1200 so you'd be like
at an 18 year old 19 year old level yeah
I don't know if that's so good for a 50
year old that's the only I don't either
I worried we don't know II don't know I
find it cuz your body goes bro we're not
made to run this high all the time
exactly the equipment is made for when
were you born
1967 the equipment's made for a 1967
Honda yeah and you're jacking us up yeah
to 2017 Ferrar and I was born black
people had only had to vote for the
three years I believe yes wasn't in 1964
yeah
yeah but you know I'm saying like your
body's not who knows again it might be
great for you I think some people you
know you know me I don't feel like I
need it I don't need it you don't need
any more in Saturday night I would say
drain
dude Saturday night him that I should
because I said to him I said to him - I
said dude I I worked out I went for a
hike then I would lifted weights then I
did two shows back to back which is
obese yeah and you know I'm physical up
there and I did him I was there on stage
for at least an hour and 15 each show
and I still had energy I was still like
yeah hands down so he said you know I
don't need it I don't think so
I don't think so I mean could you use a
little nip tuck on the old moneymaker
yeah now could we could wait a minute
could we inject those bags around your
eyes you saying could we have you saying
hey buddy everybody what's going on
where's what the [ __ ] is wrong Ryan
Collins a gym dude it's that simple
Oh count that does love the Japanese
whoops he looks Asian yeah just pull my
eyes up a little bit whoo
you know where their age comes in the
eyes you see how my droopy eyelids see
my eyelids when you look at me with my
jaw I know younger I didn't have the
droopy eyes everyone you will Maya hangs
down af scar tissue from the elbow in a
fight but yeah my hangs down I notice
fighters have thicker skin like Donald
Cerrone well you know like Wanderlei in
the Rashad Evans they had a lot of the
scart because the scar tissue builds up
since thick yeah so you can get it taken
out like Wanderlei went over the top
right you went like James Fonda yes like
face yes but they're very different
Rashad had the bags over his eyes like
shaved down because he had all so much
like scar tissue I'm there is that
something I can interest you in because
we could do a two-for-one deal I should
just maybe inject the wrinkles in your
forehead yeah but here's the problem
here's a product could get a little
taken off the beak for sure
let's send me my not this no yes but as
a man I can't go and get plastic surgery
there I can do is if I if I keep boxing
to your face and I get punched in the
top four eyes a little bit and then I
get some scar tissue oh then I can be
that I can you know how much how awesome
would be for me to go go to the doctor
and go doc got to take the scar tissue
away from eyes because all boxers in
Boggs
allow them do get it taken down though
yeah yeah I met at uh well there's this
et snow see CT scans through your brain
but they did a scan of my actual bone
structure met my skull and there's a
bunch of little cracks all over here
line fractures all oh [ __ ] yeah the
doctors like this very common in
football players and fighters um I did
both think that make sense yeah well you
did get punched right in the face by not
only by a crow cop like where you
smashed your nose the guys punch her in
the face breath yeah a lot of guys a lot
of guys my god I smiled at him and kept
going on the gals by the guys my gal
slapped me not the face first thanks for
the fracture first of all I was your
turkey date though I'm glad you asked
my turkey day was fine I was I was this
guy who is you know Joe over at scopa
last night saw Stevie blue eyes he's
back he's back he's back and thought
excited about that Stevie stand back
he's back and staying oh well more on
that it didn't go one there but I'm very
happy you're very happy and we we went
to scope it was like late night drink is
because my wife was with her girls and
they were they were tearing up my house
girls night yeah so I got your house
fast couldn't get out of the house have
you ever seen that family guy we come
downstairs and his wife goes babe it's
it's it's girls night we're having a
book club Yas
what all fantastic and cakes and we'd
love if you sat down in Joyce's like oh
I'll get right to it can't get out fast
like what see you I run away I run away
as fast as I can and my buddy Joe goes I
go how was your turkey day he goes was
good bro
I go Turkey he goes I made a duck I go
oh and he goes let me out the green and
he opens up his phone
and he starts showing me this he shows
me a duck now hold on I'm out right well
can be if it shows me a duck and any
then he shows me he goes now look at
this he start zeroing in on the turnips
and all the other things he made around
the dock he's the only guy who could
get away with it he's a drummer he's
from New York I love him already and
also he just the way he was doing it I
was like and I go I was like you're the
only person that could get away with
showing me you're done and the food that
you're cooking because you're so
detailed and you took so much time with
it that somehow I'm interested he mainly
which is impossible that's a tough
sounds like you show me pictures of the
time you went to the zoo with your
family
he was zeroing in on the old turnips I
don't know it was late at night gives
inflated mics it's late at night so it
was okay
something's not right when he got there
yeah right when I got there I feel like
it's inappropriate no you're like you
somehow he thought it is if it was after
you don't say like you're halfway no
he's like bro I mean it's like yeah look
at this thing like right let me see it
you're I'm gonna erase your number from
my phone but let me see this very cool
man oh this is this this is duck oh man
all that I bet it was how was it was it
good so I would of course make fun of
him for that oh man then you put all the
is that relish Wow Wow very cool right
now and then how many people were there
hey man let me ask you something can you
waste any more of my life that's how it
was Sasso would do it he'd go how many
people were there I don't care I don't
care but how many people were there I
don't get was it a moist I don't care
it's like but you know what might my dad
my dad he called me before Thanksgiving
because it you know I haven't been home
for the holidays and forever
let's take a chat number but if you
adjust it in your seat when you said
hasta come to dinner
oh my god my my dad calls me on
Thanksgiving as the day before and he's
going or anything on my couch god I
don't want him to bring up talking about
food and I'm all you guys ever get you
trying to get out and I'm driving down
the road I'm like well you got some good
Thanksgiving dad watch I was there maybe
next year maybe you guys come out you
know he's they care you you know your
stepmom
your stepmom is we're gonna roast a
turkey I'm like yeah that's what
everyone does man hopefully have the
sides and everything it should be good
have a good things I can't and I'll tell
you what I'm gonna
do can I tell what I'm gonna do I'm like
yeah man
and I'm like well let's gear down here
just let's go that's we're gonna we're
gonna actually deep-fry a turkey I'm
like oh my no you're not he's like it we
are you have a steak knife I can cut my
throat we are we are my dang that that's
gonna take completely different than the
roasted turkey dad he's like it does it
does you know what I hear the sarcasm
your voice out appreciate I went dad you
talking about two turkeys it's all the
turkeys turkey goes called you out
Hagar's we've never had fried chicken I
haven't you know what I have it but I
can imagine what taste like you know
what you should do death you should eat
it then call me and he goes you know
what [ __ ] you
Peter shop Papa shop and I can tell you
sarcasm that's too much oh wow well
here's the problem me my wife made a
turkey my mom made a turkey and they got
no competition
a turkey car huh and I was the mo time I
jerk off yeah because drama Turk off his
Turk off white on white Turkish why
don't why Turk and my wife my wife you
love judging that couple couple organic
turkeys and my wife was hitting me with
she goes did you eat my turkey did you
try my which one what plate and I go I
don't know I don't know they say hair
yeah cuz it's turkey so gravy on it
makes it edible
and it's because I get but mine I put
butter I rubbed butter and salt pepper
under the skin she didn't do that like
that yeah by the way like where your
wife said by the way this is better huh
it's delicious yeah you know Turkey cuz
you have it once a year if you've had
all the time to be super shape because
you have it once a year it's decent yeah
you know we did and I'm just like God we
I switched the holidays up around Joe's
family is over you know my family's
everyone's in Denver so all Joe's
family's there and we decided to just go
the old foods route and just order
everything rolls food you know what
there is though kind of bothered me
I didn't say anything but I was in bad
mood on Thanksgiving because she didn't
cook you're used to somebody yes
so it was all all like Whole Foods
pre-made everything just put it in this
pies I don't know man okay it's on the
whole foods
their ceremony to cooking and because it
brings people around but I can cook so I
would have done my own mashed potatoes I
can do my own stuffing and cranberry
I'll bring you together but also it's a
taste good the third thing skin like I
don't want that instant meal so the
whole it was alright but it was like
going around had the whole food logo I'm
like I don't like this I don't like this
so what I'm gonna do I'm be a baby I'm
Marie vault and her dad brought the only
thing homemade which were these
jalapenos ah which were cream cheese and
then wrapped in bacon and baked sounds
very good I 16 of those so I'm on
hardcore Kiana those are keto better but
I wait 16 of those any anything else a
bag to cater cuz I'm gonna night alright
yeah yeah we'll get into that I 16 of
those jalapeno poppers didn't touch any
other food
I need 16 those two slices of pie oh my
god how was your butt how'd that feel on
your butt I mean come on you have to
[ __ ] like when that happens you have to
[ __ ] now brother 16 jalapeno poppers
wrapped in bacon cream cheese yeah I was
toxic
no you toxic you gotta call the fire
department after you take a [ __ ] didn't
give me the runs didn't you were the
wrong snow I was a tootin all you
Tooting non-stop Oh party up you did
yeah I ruined the ruin the vibe so you
were spiteful party yeah yeah farty and
then I was like oh you're making puzzles
they're like yeah yeah and I was making
fun for making pop I was like sweet
puzzle is this giant puzzle like Oh
puzzles that I got super into it but I
didn't tell anyone and then they're all
oh my god I'm like hey can you pass me
that and like know who did that like but
it smells like sulfur I'm like it might
be the hot tub keep going
hey can you pass me the bat yeah just so
you know they're like you know we don't
do the puzzle anymore first of all
puzzles annoy me everyone never got a
prob about this though building the
puzzle
I'm balls dude I'm like going through
and out it's a huge one those huge adult
puzzles from United States whole
landscape boring landscape by the way
I'm going through it turns out some
about the puzzle secondhand it's missing
a few pieces that's 45 minutes I'm like
where is this piece and I'm
hold on how many pieces coming this
puzzle like 1200 I'm like oh I'm gonna
count everyone and that we're missing
six pieces on it
where'd you get this puzzle and her
brother's like what like where did you
get this puzzle he's all Walmart Mike
didn't have wrapping on it didn't have
the prize things like no was it a
returning puzzle he's all bro if there's
one thing you don't do you [ __ ] don't
buy a second-hand puzzle you spend the
extra three dollars to a $2 $2
secondhand puzzle ever no no no
secondhand cars I understand you
secondhand puzzle go [ __ ] absolutely
not
are you trying to save the quarter that
is some Isis [ __ ] a secondhand table
that war no annoying huh and I looked
there's no way to improve these there's
no way to prove I wanted to call Mattel
whoever the [ __ ] built that thing like
yo man but diamond hold on would you get
this puzzle no no I wanna comb it okay
solve sir I want the bubble wrap still I
want the I want it from China I want to
be able to I want the seal I'll [ __ ] up
your Thanksgiving that's incredible
missing puzzle pieces the 16 jalapeno
poppers the pecan pie and the pre-made
whole food you didn't eat any chicken
you ate some turkey I had one slice of
turkey and revolt that was it so you
were soggy but resistor and just kept
popping them killed your girl give you a
hard time
no no cooking cuz that because what I
when I reef all I do it on the inside I
just get real quiet sit my coffee in the
back we've taken my son for a long walk
God for hours yeah you see that's what
happens my acting teacher used to take
people who would rush through scenes and
acting and he would say you want to know
what I want what I think you should do I
think already goes I think you should
start cooking your own meals because I
know you don't
and sure enough to never would is why he
said well you go cook you have to go to
the supermarket you got to pick out all
the ingredients you got to look at them
take your time and there's that detail
those details then you put it all
together when you cook properly
appreciate it more you appreciate it are
and it's how you should live your life
is that you create a work of art when
you when you cook mmm and so he'd make
people cook I'll make some mean-ass
taters to boy yeah you cook I can cook
you may I got that out girl like a
[ __ ]
I'm doing Rogen's podcast tomorrow and
if you think I'm not if you think I'm
not gonna raid his freezer for ELQ I'm
taking ELQ it would build I would sell I
always tell them I never have the hell
company's ago i'll give some after than
I just always forget you have some know
yeah yeah yeah I take you should give me
some I take not gonna know I'll bring it
is he grounded out
yeah ground and I'll get some steak he's
a little stingy with the old elk steaks
by the way here here's more ground say I
might get my way over them with that
back strap right there
you're the old back don't look over here
look over here I tried taking my son to
his first movie in the movie theater to
Coco but first like Mexican Disney movie
yeah it's a it's killing in the
box-office makes those most successful
movie there's all this hype around out
I'm like em take my son to that so we go
that new mall century Century City
across from CA yeah it's a ridiculous
mall amazing there's Javier's we need to
go there okay so half years making
restaurant there anyways take him in
there and I'm like I got E if he likes
movie he I can get through like an hour
20 minutes well no longer than that
otherwise he's gonna freak out and start
throwing [ __ ] at everyone yeah we sit
down the movie it's all good he's loving
the screen there's a few previews and
then you know what Disney you [ __ ] me
because what they decided to do is put a
short film in there about frozen with
Olaf that's about 30 minutes long which
is super boring not only for the adults
but the kids who don't give a [ __ ] about
a talking snowman that sings so the mood
so something about it's a 215 movie the
actual movie didn't start to almost 3:15
because of previews and that shows too
long so we got maybe 10 to 15 minutes
you're in that you're there for almost
an hour before the movie yeah it's a
real problem
I see people on like complaint cuz when
it was going I was like can I go the
other parents I heard something like
what he's gonna and I'm like what the
[ __ ] am i right
how's that damn week am i right yes
we're just gonna start what are we doing
like a chill bro chill still ridiculous
and then you know he just didn't want to
sit so I watched me 15 minutes of Coker
looked amazing and then we left
but you dissing you [ __ ] ridiculous you
I mean you're talking about the shorts
you let people know hey Koko's this but
if you got a little tongue
it's reduce it but also but also the
three four five six years everyone was
like they thought they're in the wrong
movie right like we were get up walking
out cuz it's a half an hour or at least
25 minutes of a some brand a movie yeah
then you're not there to see no it's me
saying like hey everyone let's frozen
[ __ ] sit down and watch this right
[ __ ] up I want to see Coco now you
look so good man
it looked great but they take all that
they try to make it as authentic as
possible you ever have any people who
give you sob stories on Thanksgiving
like you're like my buddy was like well
I was you know what I did on
Thanksgiving really I was biking I went
for a long bike ride I found myself in a
gas station grab myself a hot dog that
was my Thanksgiving dinner is he looking
for
dead air I'm like okay well I was with
my family see you later see ya not
really not too much holidays can get two
people depressed for sure I get a little
sick because I don't see my family you
know cuz I'm not hearing my son I needed
that make a big deal about the holidays
mm just Christmas yeah that's it
yeah Thanksgiving my wife started
decorating for Christmas two years ago
Yeah right
she loves I mean I got my houses in my
neighborhood I just didn't earn anything
I know like how you covering your whole
house with lights yeah yeah my house is
decorated two days before Thanksgiving
kind of noise making me take down the
tree you're screwed no I'm not but I
don't need two months of Christmas yeah
Christmas is my favorite holiday though
you've been the Grove no they have the
biggest tree you've ever seen this I
have been there and yes I said sometimes
is there recently and yes yes you know
and it's nice there just is nice they
reach out to me they redid it and then
yeah they have that Santa's shop now
he's there he was there a little too
early for my like into a little spot
without those Santa's what grown me and
decided to do that for a gig hmm I got a
question those dudes yeah
worries me a little bit of course it's
on your lap of course I by the way an
age I talk about clowns that way that's
how 50 year old clown blowing balloons
really haven't seen clowns let's I'm
down Venice and they have dirty feet in
the probably man
something's going on like scary clowns
yeah I'm talking about these fresh clean
older and grandpa's that dress them -
Santa Claus huh I get its own task to do
it they have the real beard stuff like
that it worries me a little bit with my
son you know if there are the animation
they're old men and they just have
something to do and they love kids but
yeah I die on something a little strange
right a bit in this day and age I know
it's [ __ ] up come on man says it's a
terrible thing to even talk about but
it's true they're just like what's going
on with you man like what's your deal
what's your deal yeah excuse me well I'm
here to be Santa I get that you 7d yeah
yeah shitload of kids it's kinda has to
be kind of annoying are you trying to
give back what's your background bro do
the back kid yourself no I don't get
that down the fat down Steve you got a
little job down there yeah you mind if I
just got I don't know scope out your
background yeah license yeah it is
straight extreme it can be a little
strange right yeah if you told me that
there were Santa's in the mall who had a
likin for the kids I wouldn't be
surprised know if Sean's like a you know
out of 100 Santa's 90 of them have chubs
the entire time when the kids and I went
oh yeah no [ __ ] stop ruining Christmas
damn it but I hate God but he says you
can all just write any like I don't know
man I was still tired hey keep it
skeptical with this guy keep you know
damn well death can buy it whatever you
want not that [ __ ] guy I know I'm
saying let me ruin Santa Claus for you
right now for your own safety
yeah you gotta get you know I don't want
any dirty deed that seems to be cracking
I'm Jim when no one else I heard whoa
I'm done with it now but Punisher oh
yeah boy doves in it
here's a quick cameo he's a radio DJ but
when he came on I got super crunk yeah
Punisher series is so God hosted about
it I was so crunk I'm so glad I could
it's so so good actor so so good how the
guy who doesn't fury yet from walking
dead yeah yeah so Jon Bernthal yes yes
yeah yeah he's so my friends friends
with him says he's a real dude a real
good guy like a cool
yeah he's so [ __ ] good in it how did
the movie is extremely violent which I
typically don't like oh it's not serious
the movie it's a serious sorry it's a
say ok it's a 13-part series on Netflix
from the Marvel I'm sure but it is so
goddamn good you can see why they
delayed this look 9 out of 10 on IMDB I
don't see why they delayed this happened
er the Vegas Massacre shooting because
like even again for me I'm gonna tell
the dudes dude I like enough guns chicks
dicks yeah and this was intent like even
for me I'm like goddamn that's violent
but it's so well done really it's so
what is that what is the gist who is he
he's a guy he Basie he's a secret like
works for he's a former Special Forces
guy and they were in a crew where this
crew was told by the government to do
certain acts that were super illegal and
then he comes back home and to keep it
under wrap they murdered his family and
tried murdering him and a bunch of other
guys involved in how it's time to avenge
because they murdered his family got
revenge but it's crazy man yeah yeah
it's so good it is so so good man yeah
it's rare I post about shows that I'm
watching I was like you know I get this
thing is so goddamn good I guess
daredevil is right up there to the
series cuz I don't like like I like
spider-man but I don't like like
transformers or like the Hulk I don't
like all that [ __ ] like where it's
real kitty like this is more realized
got a great face I mean he's perfect for
the role he was in the accountant - yes
yeah he's so good yeah yes good Fran
he's been out of a long time so it's
always cool to see a guy the only 41
sunny 41 is only 40 well still no I'm
just saying 41 is doing well he's having
yes it's killing it this is what it's
supposed to happen for him he's yeah
he's so good in it be you got to see I
can't wait this is not so good I can't
wait I cannot wait okay
key key key key key he kills about 90 or
they so many people die in it and I'm
like not a spoiler but he he has revenge
on the guy that caused all this you know
and you hate that character that caused
all this you fight you want
died so bad and the spoiler alert
spoiler alert I'm Punisher here
so skip fast-forward but he gets revenge
on the guy who was didn't do the killing
but ordered to kill yes and you cannot
stand that character and the way he
kills that character is so satisfying
exactly how you would want to kill
someone that killed your family
it's exactly how you'd want really I
don't know I got a watch when he did it
I got a watch I got yeah it's so far you
to say that you don't want violence no
so what blousing you dumped it so check
this out that I was shooting this I went
shooting in Utah guns yep and my dad
will always bring me to the thing and
it's a range where you can shoot machine
gun a fully automatic machine gun a saw
you can shoot a ar-15 shoot everything
you want and I'll just I'll just get the
whole [ __ ] arsenal and then I said
I'm looking for a gun for my for home
protection I got guns but I want
something you know I want something that
you know is gonna really do it he goes
this guy was the head of the SWAT team
you tell SWAT team he goes well I would
recommend the governor that's what I use
I went the governor he goes Smith &
Wesson governor said 10 and he pulls out
this revolver the big one it's a big
heavy revolver but I go honey swing that
up and I go what's that he goes well
this hold this hold this will take up 45
slugs but it also take it also take
essentially shotgun shells smaller ones
double up triple lot which is it shoots
out a disc well there you go
it shoots out a disc and it'll spray so
it's kinda shotgun so you and it has a
laser on it so you just [ __ ] that and
just point that laser you're not gonna
worry about it and it's just cuz a good
news and basically you just aim in the
direction and whoever's coming up your
stairs no Mike yeah he's not having a
good day you ain't having a good day
that's the big boil yeah I may have to
get myself one of those they have to get
you just in case the zombie apocalypse
happens and I got a shoot in the general
direction well you know I you I hae got
got two guns our neighbor's house got
broken into so when I talked to the cop
he's like you have guns I'm like yeah
he's like I would I would you know I
would get guns the bad guys have guns
that's going on around here
so you know you have to do go through
the ten day trial period yeah you're
gonna pick the guns up you know so we
shot gun and then a nine-millimeter
okay well shotgun and do it though but
now that I wouldn't this is the worst
watch let me see your hands see your
hands yeah that's good what kind of what
kind of a gun see how long how long
you'll do that a Glock 19 yeah that's
you've got a good gun for you yeah make
a fist make a fist hey guys it's good
art don't hope don't kill the gun don't
kill the guy
lovers I would recommend that you
practice shooting those guns which I
have yeah
which I have the shotgun you only need
too much practice I'd say just name it a
minute 12-gauge yeah it's got a kick for
your girl she needs to kind of practice
not shooting that shotgun yeah she grew
up shooting guns can we she did her
dad's a cop right Stephanie your girl by
the way your girls not taking any
[ __ ] yeah yeah you're the one who
might be like I'd rather just Schumann
legging them let me get my hands on
finish shooting yeah get your hands on
and put and put the squeeze on them yeah
I don't kill you shoot these shoes like
it's like now listen I like to shoot him
in the dick now I got put put the
squeeze on you now now it's gonna get
nasty and put you see the Punisher yeah
that's what I'm gonna do here mm-hmm
yeah never you know never shoot ever
perpetrator with when he's leaving your
house and never even when he has a bunch
of stuff in his hands if he's stealing
let him go don't kill him yeah because
it's you don't want to deal with that
[ __ ] you're gonna get sued by the family
also cops cops say the other stuff like
this cop who that was dealing with our
neighbors yeah I asked about that I said
if there he was if he's in your house I
promise you you're fine yeah
they could they could sue the face he
said you'd be fine even if they did that
so cause that's why I told him he's like
you you'd be fine what I promised you'd
be fun yeah yeah just especially if they
did damage to your house and you find
him in the house you have a drawer if
he's come up the stairs for me for me
it's like I have a child I don't care
who you're cut well you know I got a
here's the thing that bothers me night
text you and I takes rogue in this is if
you look at the statistics of gun owners
your child is 11 times more likely to
die by again yes because it hands their
house so what you have to do is get a I
believe a safe yeah
that is finger activated so you don't
have to be all my combination you want
you put your finger on that safe and it
opens it's very important and and you
know if you want if it's a gun and you
have to be ready the gun should probably
be ready to go yeah yeah and now it's
always but I wonder feel statistics are
if with people with safe is safe that's
are always very tricky when it comes I
know but when you look at it like the
stats aren't for the pro-gun you know
because kids up grab a gun they're
playing with it there's a lot of
problems with with having a gun in the
house if you're not an honorable I know
I just thought that I love the Punisher
stuff I'm not a gun guy yeah I don't
really like them I don't really believe
in them yeah I don't I don't think
they're the best answer gun people will
usually tell you that yeah safety yeah
safe but education talk to your kids
about guns talk like they have to
understand and no guns the problem is
their friends come over and they don't
know that's the issue yeah it's always a
risk that but I don't know what those
stats are with people with safes and
stuff like that I don't know I don't
know I just don't want to be left with
no recourse if dudes are coming into my
house I know we're doing bad guys have
what you know guys meet the governor do
shotgun decay and for whatever reason I
miss you guys want to get and a hand
friendly we didn't do that to this
problem pick your poison his problem the
old shoddy shot yeah let me get my dick
beaters around yeah him get my shovers
let me get my squeezes on yeah I'd love
to be that I'd love to have your
skillset in your size because I'd be a
lot of fun you hey I know
listen guys you came in with bats came
with your hands try to intimidate me but
noone got that not to squeeze both you
to death so you pull your pants and you
pass out and they come to and they their
hands are tied with your shoes some
scary [ __ ] man
lately I've been balls deep in the
Charles Manson stuff since got out you
know when I've been reading a lot of
stuff horrible right when you actually
read what those guys did it well what
did their murders yes obviously horrible
what's fascinating is his story and how
he came to to become the serial killer
and how he wanted to really it was his
rejection from Hollywood he want to be a
star like you know
and he got in with the music industry
and they're like we're good man and he
got rejected I didn't know Hollywood he
want to be famous so you know he he came
up from a whole horrible childhood wood
could play the guitar really well and
then went to San Francisco and when in
prison he learned how to like manipulate
women he got close to pimps so he was
pimping a lot of girls a lot of girls
making money and then he wanted to start
a cult and you know it was like motivate
with steal other people's material like
to trying to influence all these people
so then he got the small cult around him
in San Francisco and then drove down
he's in Venice and then went to Topanga
Canyon but his whole reason for come to
LA was to get famous you know he lived
in the Beach Boys drummer's house what
and bring him up when he was young he
would mingle with all the celebrities
like tons of celebrities the Beach Boys
Oh way into paying you the door all
sorts of people and he was a musician a
musician and so he's a good-looking guy
when he was younger isn't he I mean he
is he but like take a look at him like
what with the with the beard and the
long hair I mean he's he's not God right
maybe yeah he's all right like it either
but he was obviously very charming stuff
like that but his whole thing was is so
he actually got to record almost a demo
with the head of Universal Records he
got in close with him because his
connection of the Beach Boys and all
this stuff and this guy that he was in
cart incarcerated with had a connection
to the guy from Universal Music so he
goes I bring him in he has a meeting
with the head of Universal Music but he
has his three girls there he brought him
with him his followers and the guy
wasn't impressed with his music meaning
that he goes hold on he liked to control
yet over the women it was oh yeah we can
figure it out we'll have you do a demo
so he gets to the studio of Universal to
record a demo to see if they're gonna
sign him and he's never been in like
that serious of a situation he hated the
the mic he hated them to produce time
what to do so he just had a meltdown of
course and the producer was like oh it's
all good man once you're ready work on
your music we'll bring you back
they seem like don't call us we'll call
you let's see if it actually happened
sure well uh Madson to get to heart was
like oh they're gonna call me said
worked on his music
they just kept getting rejected and
that's why freaked out that's why I
started attacking Hollywood actresses
and driving around going crazy Wow yeah
Wow who's this injection that's
fascinating I know right to meet so
fascinating his his is well you know
he'll are the hollow Hitler a lot of
historians will always honor the fact
that he never he didn't get accepted
into the Vienna School of the Arts he
wanted to be an artist and he couldn't
draw human figures he could draw
buildings really well but he couldn't
draw how ironic right how interesting
and so a lot of people always the
historians always sort of say if he had
been accepted into the Vienna School for
the Arts and he had been an artist the
course of history might have been very
different but he was this insanely
charismatic man who you know obviously
was a sociopath but but they exact netic
some skills yeah and you came about in a
time when Germany was humiliated and all
that stuff and was able to say we're
gonna make noise I'm grading the same
thing you know cuz these guys who pull
off this stuff with Austria charming but
the rustled really intelligent
yes they're super dark but they're still
intelligent like Charles Manson's IQ was
through the roof that's that I have no
doubt is Ike use any music of him like
recorded I don't they said his IQs
through the roof and he but also with
with women the stuff you do with the
women oh yeah like he would you know
manipulate they pay for all his bills
and then he got always you can't see
have sex women if you want to join a
thing oh you'd have to go with Manson
one on one for a few days so he could
feel you out and if you refused to suck
that serial killers dick yeah they like
you're probably not for this leave yeah
that's what calls figures do yeah that's
what you're resist leave they've done a
lot of say a lot of cults are basically
men who want to have sex with young
women and girls by the way his favorite
was a fourteen-year-old yeah of course
fourteen surprised that that's very
common he had old faithful I think her
name was Mary
and he would whoop her ass so the other
ones would know if you pissed Charles
off for said no this would happen to you
she'd always do it to her yeah this
fourteen-year-old but he was obsessed
with the Beatles and how fast they got
famous so he would you know try to
translate their songs to his followers
being like this
to me and I'm gonna do exactly that
helped her skelter was about for about
him so even even when they committed the
murder in their helter skelter they
spelt that wrong he's [ __ ] morons but
you see how stupid they are so when they
first killed that girl she know when
that no that was that wasn't the first
kill though there's a kill before that
the guy who did that got caught this
house stupid there they thought by that
murder then they'd want to start a race
war they killed a girl just out of
nowhere yeah they killed uh I think it
was a man they killed a man before that
there's actually murder even before that
but the ones that are famous yeah the
infamous
the the murder before the Sharon Tate
one they killed her that guy she got
caught like two weeks later they got
caught right right away they got caught
but then when they wrote on the wall
Manson was like oh [ __ ] and they thought
if they commit more murders this house
night stupid they are even though we say
Manson smart well-educated he they
thought if they commit more murders the
police would go oh that guy's actually
innocent cuz look at all the murders
still going on so they thought the more
they did right that guy was gonna get
out prison that's not crazy oh because
oh yeah there must be a solution country
well no this is pretty easy to figure
out
Wow crazy [ __ ] man but a lot of it took
place the Topanga Kane and limit opinion
Canyon yeah well when they kill Sharon
Tate she was like eight months pregnant
and they killed everyone else and then
she was in the back again she's
Hollywood so his resistance against
Hollywood and [ __ ] all yeah they reject
almond Polanski's wife correct Wow
correct it's crazy but his his ties to
Hollywood his rejection Hollywood and
how he became about is fast is a song by
him that's what it says you want some I
hear let me hear it on YouTube
the time keeps on
think your loving baby and now you do
can you feel he's not bad I hate to say
it this is real it's good this is very
real we're not jamming out to Charles
Manson okay to say that he's got his
contact it will disappear so he would
get in with Hollywood and in the music
industry and people were like yeah you
dude you have what it takes to be a star
they really didn't know but thank you
have what teacher tasting when it's time
to put up or shut they're like we're
good man something weird about yeah of
course it's not weird but it's
interesting cuz his voice is legit isn't
it yeah that's why he thought he could
make it no one thought he can make it
and then like I said when it was
actually go time he would melt you'd
have a meltdown because they were
telling what to do you know try this try
this and he hated so let me ask you a
question
this is a really uncomfortable question
if somebody's really great it like just
say he was amazing it songs he wrote ten
of those songs and then let's say cuz
they were talking about Salvador Dali
one of the great the the one of the
greatest painters of all time and he was
a ghastly human being he would he bit
bats in half he did all kind a lot of
ways really Oh like he was a bad like
ghastly according to this article that I
had read so if if someone like that is
so bad but he makes incredible art let's
just say he kills people let's say he's
a [ __ ] horrible person what do you
what do you do with his art what does
that shame child so you're basically
saying if Charles Manson worked out if
he was a great artist well fine then
killed seven people like let's say let's
say John Mayer was Charles Manson like
in all this great music and then you
find out soon by the way you know he
didn't actually kill he didn't actually
kill hell he never killed it oh no he
you know right so he again the infant
Smurfs he didn't commit yet old people
do it he taught that it all well there
he did kill man before that he did it
was a drug dealer who threatened his
family like do what drove down to the
valley and shot him in the chest he
threatened his family that's kind of
something that as men we'd go ha ha
in his family meaning his followers okay
not as like wifing rights daddy even
that as Americans we'd all go okay he
just shot a dude in the chassis he's a
drug dealer
like you you would you would forgive him
that it's what he what he got his people
to do which was the most horrible thing
all this again all his stuff what I'm
saying is we're not here that what do
you want what do you do with it like
what do you do with a ma say a monster a
guy who rapes kills whatever it might be
or you find out that he and yet he's a
great artist what what is that you you I
guess you have to separate the desert
does does it yeah well what is his
artists undeniable like Tommy's I dream
Salvador Dali but if Dali was around
today he'd never make it he made around
back then right as it didn't travel the
word didn't track sure so the people
this town it was awful okay let me do it
let me do you one even better like so
say he's a sexual deviant let's say he's
saying like the Harvey Weinstein movie
but should we just revolt all Harvey
right it's a good example and we've all
his great movies he made great he made
great movies and artists a lot of those
movies would never be made a fool of
Harvey Weinstein yeah and you know we've
talked to people in the business said
one that one of the the dark secret of
why he was left alone for so long he's
so [ __ ] talented and making movies
all the few people were making so much
money and all of a sudden you know that
that's what's interesting about the ad
the Hollywood standing up for Roman
Polanski clapping you know let him free
he got a Lifetime Achievement Award but
he we know what he did right okay I saw
Kevin Spacey the uh I think it was
Austin Powers the second gold member
whichever one was that was on and Kevin
Spacey plays I think dr. evil yeah how
the cock-eyed like I went oh there's
Kevin Spacey I can't believe they put
this movie on I'm so good at playing bad
guys right so good thing of him in seven
yeah the [ __ ] boss and he can tap
into that dark side but Michael
underlies do you think Kevin Spacey is
fine if he hadn't done it to a
fourteen-year-old and it was just yeah
me too he if he was just a guy who was
always put his hands on because most of
the the complaints about Kevin Spacey
are all yeah he was a Lech he would put
grab guys massage them grab
don't be like yeah yeah okay he'd never
come back it's when which is a double
standard course boots we're like I'll do
for you know why because those boots
could punch Kevin's face in the face yes
you know yes career-wise he could shunt
him so they began screwed but if it was
women he'd be screwed it's up to us guys
to always call out the real predators
like the dudes don't know them yeah you
don't know I don't have any friends
who'd do that that's right I did like
what the [ __ ] that's what I'm saying
something I was like men actually don't
like sexual deviance in their myths even
jail the rapist have to be protected but
this is a problem people come on let's
say you're 26 you just landed your gig
on Goldbergs yeah you're there and the
director whoever you calls the shots
you see grabbing the extras and doing
their thing sure you're not saying [ __ ]
I've seen as soon as you do I'm sure but
as soon as you do you like what the guy
that plays Jim - you know he's fired you
know matter well your phone else that's
right that's what you can't do this
right that's right that's exactly right
I mean it would be even worse it with
Harvey Weinstein like I always say don't
blame the women for not coming forward
you don't understand what he would do to
you office you know but that's the
answering question I you know I think
with Salvador Dali he was lucky at the
time he did it but if it was today's
world you'd be so screwed so screw both
well think about just take all Jayco Jay
Johnson yeah so first of all us see
they've erased every record he has right
you know you can't there's nothing above
his illustrations on the wall painted
over
besides Metro fee gone Wow they've sold
it Amy
any resemblance of OJ Simpson he's not
even allowed on the field he they've
completely erased so it's kind of
similar yeah any movie gone but his
paintings go for though will you say
you've heard the difference either
Salvador Dali was that was a serial
killer let's just say that he wasn't but
let's just say he was um like I think
his paintings still go for even more
money hundred percent right now like if
you could get a painting from Jack the
Ripper let's say it's old screwing into
the one painting it goes for millions of
dollars yeah but that's but again that's
because it's so old school that society
can't relate to a but if say a
phenomenal artist did it now you're
rudeness so what about the idea that
human beings are complicated right and
they some people have really really
talented of genes they're great as
something they work really hard but they
have a they have a side of themselves
it's a pathology they can't control so
exactly like someone who's who eats too
much is really heavy smokes too much
Gamble's and then somebody who has a
sexual addiction interesting did
whatever it's actual did I know society
shuns well there's no gray or I know
which is interesting to me we're all
that ways if you see a heavy inaudible
prom
you know I struggle with food myself but
if you have a problem in your 400 pounds
yeah and you're you know an executive or
whatever you are your boss of somebody
yourself unless you have a problem yeah
but you're hurting yourself and somebody
please let's say that that that that
boss is same role same guy and his
addiction isn't food it's women however
he's not he's not raping him or he's not
you know changing the careers yeah but
let's say he's paint for professionals
or he's just hooking up with his
grandmother problem we don't society
would shun that guy yeah I think that's
a bummer
why no no I mean in other words onset um
yeah yeah you shouldn't shun you know
it's the same issue he just likes women
but if he's if he's in a position where
he's he's like [ __ ] with them make
I'm not I'm saying he's just the high
level and he's a womanizer he's a
womanizer there's nothing wrong now I
agree let's say he's a high level exact
and he's like no I just I date a lot of
girls I have a different girl every
single week but he's a good dude yeah
who cares yeah nobody cares and that's
where we have to draw the distinction
because it cuz it's a disservice to
women who have really suffered from real
sexual harassment and [ __ ] like that
where they come to work every day and
they feel like they think they feel like
they're nervous to even be around yeah I
don't know what what you do want to do
with somebody's [ __ ] art though what
do you do do you know he's lucky because
you know you look at him 6.8 11 million
dollars twenty two million dollars
portrait Paul Elena but Kevin Spacey's
an amazing actress great we still you
see you'll be shunned
here will be huh he'd be shunned he's
not me good Joe Paterno you know about
Joe Park no so Joe paw he he didn't do
it he didn't commit the act but he did
not safety and speak
didn't know about it yes did he talk to
the cops about it didn't know yeah I
think he actually covered for Sandusky
so what happens Joe pahu most Williams
coach of all time tell statue down right
they tore statue down they've a race
it was the Joe Paterno Center that's
gone what I I think a bunch of his wins
those are done they say no wins from
damn that so if you do that's fair yes
because he because he knew about it and
didn't say see if you knew but this is
my you you had a child molesters working
for you you go to the you I don't give a
[ __ ] here I'm going you you raped
children you molest I'm going to the
[ __ ] cops right now
there's nothing you know what I mean
there's certain things where you're like
oh well that's all that's in that's a
special kind of you know what's strange
is like isn't it two different
categories like granted Sandusky awful
horrible things that guy should rot in a
deep deep dark hell yeah but what's that
have to do with didn't win in football
games what those kids did on the field
why are they getting the losses in the
careers take that way that's the quite a
history of Penn State's forever turn
tarnish you know because of that that's
the question also I don't know the whole
deal was per turn out but I guess if he
knew that is he did that's what they're
saw that's not sex [ __ ] that's know ops
he passed away and this didn't help him
they said the stress of this actually
made him best way faster I'm sure but
after he passed away then the stuff came
out that he knew this Greg chef chef ro
show Pharaoh a free his name Chaparro I
think Shapiro nope but he was the he's
the defense coordinator for Ohio State
accepts the job at Tennessee get ready
for this gonna make you man I know he
accepts the job at Tennessee
one of the most illustrious jobs in
college football usually attend see the
Vols
doesn't get much bigger SEC football
Tennessee [ __ ] huge to have that job
as big-time he accepts the job Oceano
Schiano Greg Schiano
great job ridiculous coach coach at
Tampa Bay coach at Rutgers when they had
a Greg although handsome rugged man
phenomenal coach yeah accepts job at
Tennessee the student and the city don't
like him as a coach you know what they
do
well he worked for Penn State when
Sandusky and Paterno did he's a child
molester to insensate do so there's a
revolt around the vault online community
you know what happened today they went
on and I went off from the job where old
no never mind so and he had nothing to
do with it he has nothing to do with it
that's so fun so they went oh your dream
job no no no we don't think you're right
coach what can we pull out oh he was
part of the Penn State thing and then
and then Tennessee having zero [ __ ]
balls don't stick up for him go he's a
great coach he actually had nothing to
do with it
the records show him nothing no
knowledge of it had cutlass yep and but
they have no [ __ ] backbone so an
upside
we're actually retract the job Wow gross
because the students shame of alumni
threw a fit shame on them and put up
signs saying dusky Schiano Singh guy and
he had nothing to do it now did nothing
to I knew nothing about nothing
[ __ ] off loses his dream job yeah yeah
man it's look at that UT Vols deal with
Ohio State's Greg Schiano
unravels after backlash from fans how
crazy is that
it's no good cuz these friends go no we
don't think he's good fit so let's pull
out this [ __ ] so he doesn't get a
job it's terrible man a wave of backlash
from the fans state politicians local
businesses owners disrupted deal Sunday
that would have made Ohio State defense
coroner Greg Schiano
Tennessee's next coach the blow back
caused the deal Tom Ravel keep going to
see that it's so weird to get caught up
in that keeps growing up and he did
nothing no right there look at the
frustration centered in part around
testimony released by Philadelphia Court
in 2016 pertaining to the jury skin the
Jerry Sandusky case shayana a 51 year
old New Jersey native was on staff at
Penn State from 1999 to five so former
Penn State staffer Mike McQueary talked
about that the fellow assistant Tom
Bradley told me carry that Shabana was
aware of the child sex abuse incident by
Cintas News okay so sheesh Schiano and
Bradley denied having knowledge of it so
some guy said oh they did know yes
accusation you're guilty that's the but
the courts didn't find anything right
there's no there's no actual evidence
we're guilty you are guilty by
accusation nowadays you are easy I've
had [ __ ] I've had people who are I
know people who are lawyers and
insurance people talk to tell tell
everybody I know get insurance right now
I don't do anything doesn't matter it
doesn't matter an accusation can ruin
everything for you that's the world
we're living in
you know what though I always look at it
this way like over the course of history
when a woman would get raped everywhere
she had no recourse how many how many
women have been raped and they said I
was raped in the people go well you kind
of deserved it you were wearing a short
skirt you were in his room this is a
history of that sort of it until very
recently it wasn't even a crime it was a
crime against the man you were with
because it was you were his property
it's old school
yeah but you can't play like no you go
I'll write some tell me all right I for
a night how many women we got raped and
now guys you're screwed
whoa whoa prepa we need proportion this
is a horrible segue and I'm not trying
to correlate them but Joe one to watch
the Miss Universe pageant last night you
ever watched that I've not sir oh my
word really that is some silly [ __ ] is
that is some silly ass job making a levy
for being a judge on that I love her
that you know they it's it's all Europe
you know Ireland Great Britain there's
China which she actually got passed to
the finest another one is just no no
business being there
bring her up what's your name young miss
China all right well take it easy well
there's only one for God I never take it
easy bill I need you to calm down for a
sec and it's personality too they asked
some questions and what we do oceans our
silliest about world peace question went
you know it's Steve Harvey hope they're
paying much because you know Steve
Harvey do be like this some sources you
never when he got here and announced the
wrong one I was thinking Steve saying
some silly [ __ ] she's not bad there's
bathing suits her but this little holes
bit of don't though the whole spiel of
it yeah they come out in there and she
won Miss China won
no oh god no I'm surprised funny - take
it easy bro
who won it's Steve Harvey place before
um uh I forget who won okay everyone we
see can you bring up who won brother let
me itch I got this girl wow that's not
her is it you know what she looks very
similar that's like no racist swimsuit
pageant see you rock the wrong way in
Las Vegas
Miss Universe winner yeah 2017 I think
I'll just watch I'm like what is going
on here yeah I think I had a little
something to do with her one of one of
the Demi repeaters where's she from
don't you're on some more gorgeous but
it's just like yeah what a silly event
yeah South Africa South Africa hmm yeah
yeah she's pretty there you go it's just
a silly event a little bit little bit
then like I'm I'm gonna take this and
I'm gonna use this platform to change
the world okay I'm gonna change the
world one bikini at a time I'm just no I
know cuz you're don't you don't shoot
that guy Miss America Miss Universe
wouldn't approve I'd saw her make a
speech who is Vanessa Vanessa Williams
was Miss Universe I believe yeah and
then they stripped her of the title
because she posed for penthouse yes
naked now I don't know if you've seen
those pictures but she's about as hot as
a human gets read it I would have given
her second crown me too given her second
go to your most beautiful naked yes you
want not only with very little clothing
on but also but Nate I mean no crazy and
Rick Fox who was married to her for a
long time you want to talk about a dime
piece of human time feels like you man a
very have children I think they should
yes they do it if they do yes they do
have children and you know he's you know
say on that one up but if so what's some
silly [ __ ] man yeah yeah I agree with
you I agree but you know to each its own
miss universe and what it means to root
for everybody black a lot of black girls
up in this universe it's alright there's
a lot of black contestants I like that
fro I like that it's a good look
yeah that's cool I'm gonna piss hard
meet you man let's go pee we'll be back
back for that long period
we're back we're back yeah dude again
this is in a sponsor I don't [ __ ] with
him at all I don't nothing about them
trying on keto I get sceeto flew a
little bit right now yeah that's where
you have withdrawals you've got ki tarah
I'm gonna I'm hard in the paint link you
know why I made all my pre-made meals
yeah a lot of stuff come up in January
bro January February so you wanna be I
get back on the train you I like being
iodine I don't like you whatever I want
to feel lazy you want to be tight you
want to be tight
Neelix my best you want to tighten up
around the face and the tummy yeah you
know how it goes bro and keyed up for me
great does that and you know three
months [ __ ] me when I go out with you
and that you can't kitty easy though
yeah I know we use I give you my bread
bro smack your [ __ ] lips at the pizza
mmm
is it good I do miss it is it good and
your your lording over me your lord what
I knew is before I knew I was gonna do
this the day after Thanksgiving so for
about I don't know week and a half me to
excite whatever I want whenever I wanted
so I went nuts and I'm just over
everything I'm over all the shitty food
but again I so you can't you know
there's no sugar and keto but this
Waterloo sparkling water
they have watermelon but there's no
artificial sweeteners or it's just
natural yeah it is so goddamn fresh here
this is so you can open that it says
legendary tastes I can open it yeah I
got at Whole Foods I was like I need
some sort of taste zero calories zero
sugar zero sodium try that open that
this is not a dad I have nothing doing I
don't have no them sparkling try that
that's watermelon I prefer the
grapefruit though if you can't have
flavored [ __ ] yeah a special flavor
sparkling water it's not yeah it's
working well done yeah right it's
ultra-filtered organic and [ __ ] as fresh
but it's saving me right now in this
cute I'll make it yeah that's sweet tea
they'll make you think you have
something sweet in your mouth but you
don't that's what she said that's funny
too is is not there's no sugar but it
feels like this sugar in it mm-hmm
anyways
shut up to Waterloo um where were we at
during the break you got is talking
about this South Carolina omj brought up
the girl that [ __ ] up this is
hilarious yeah have you ever seen this
me this is the
petition that ultimately determines
their fate mayor for my moment the
ladies will have to demonstrate their
ability to answer a thought-provoking
final question it sounds simple said
than done
it's Mario Lopez owned the whole country
as what a choice here's how it works our
panel of judges for to when she gets up
there oh did any Mario Lopez box to
recent polls have shown 1/5 of Americans
can't locate the US on a world map why
do you think this is I personally
believe that us Americans are unable to
do so because sama people out there in
our nation don't have maps and I believe
that our education like such as in South
Africa and the Iraq everywhere like such
as and I believe that they should our
education over here in the US should
help the US or should help South Africa
and should help the Iraq and the Asian
Cup or we will be able to build up our
ki get minor Lopez trying not to laugh
thank you very much South cross she got
nervous such as yeah she's out though we
don't have math and such as that's
that's very tough sounds rough that's
yeah if I wasn't so old I would laugh
but I feel bad for this whole area such
as yeah just she got like a [ __ ] a lot
of attention for that yeah like people
obviously people she got famous for she
data such as well such as girl yes she
was on touch point oh well what else get
Jen um this one that you showed me a
transgender weightlifter is getting
backlash because she got accepted to the
Commonwealth Games to represent New
Zealand as a female when she was a male
before correct yep she's a male to
female hormones then comes back
Commonwealth Games and destroying
obvious yeah I think that's I just have
I have a problem with it and it doesn't
mean I am
I'm transphobic it's just not fair
because he has a dif
scoffs but check this out beach 39 year
old was a national junior record holder
in the male 105 kilogram class before
transition or mid 30s so before he was
already a world-class lifter cuz I'm a
chick I'm competing the female game
that's ridiculous
I think I think it's unfair I do I mean
you're dealing with a different skeletal
structure you're dealing with a
different muscular structure I know
you're taking you had an operation and
you're taking estrogen but you still
have an X Y chromosome and there are
certain advantages to hunger will this
the Australian weightlifting Federation
chief executive Michael kealan put make
some good points puts we're in the we're
in a power sport which is normally
related to masks and tendencies where
you've got the aggression you've got the
right hormones then you can lift the
bigger weights if you've been a male and
you've lifted certain weights and then
you've suddenly transitioned a female
then psychologically you know you've
lift lifted those weights before because
I personally don't think it's a level
playing field that's my personal view
it's not and I think it's shared by a
lot of people no it's not I agree and it
has nothing to do with being trans
phobic he can go oh you can live what
other foot you want yeah but this is a
little weird that's not so and this is
where we get into ideology and all that
stuff I mean you know for me it's a
tough one but I would not allow people
who have that much of an advantage in
sports like that but also in Australia
the transgender there's debate the
Australian former male handball player
Hanna mount C was barred because she
wanted to play in the women's
competition yeah but I get that I just
think it's I don't is not fair it's not
fair it's it we're talking it's not fair
because I'm responsive to evidence it's
not fair because of the physiological
differences regardless of the the treat
the hormone treatment in this yeah this
might sound [ __ ] up but it was just
not enough but because we're in the
empathy of this transgender people since
sexualities like this and it's out in
the public but if you had a League of
all transgenders that would be fine
right like all males that switch to
females think that one propagated do
because how
how much testosterone you have in your
body is this you're taking testosterone
if you're a man so in that case but if
they will like compete you gotta have
some sort of but it's not gonna happen
troll it's gonna be the guy who is the
best doctor because then you can take
more testosterone you can take more
whatever it is to you'd get it's very
very it's a very this is a very weight
lifting yes
why would I get mad at is when I when
when people bring up the fact that this
is not a level playing field regardless
of whether or not you have the operation
people then say that you are XY and Z
and it's not fair but that is the case
and you you get huge backlash from the
lunatic fringe on the ideological
lecture oh I don't even touch chin do we
have any update on the guy who flew the
rock did you fall yeah yeah did here it
is are we are we in he canceled it third
one in broke great yeah he canceled it
why the first thing was his rocket
launcher didn't work well they broke in
the driveway
that's why shelf but then he said he got
it fixed on Wednesday but then the
Bureau of Land Management they didn't
give a permit so he has to work on the
permit okay hey bro I get idea and these
are all things that you probably should
have went over before you launch into
space that's that's him there that's in
there oh my god he looks normal but he
looks like he's all there my thing is is
this is all stuff you should have gone
over before launch yourself into space
like things should have thought of do
we're never gonna know if the if the
earth is a flat petri dish with an ice
wall around it we're just never gonna
know if if those those scientific place
I can see how crazy his eyes tell a
story the by story I mean crazy story
[Music]
[Laughter]
but uh let me introduce you guys to Mad
Mike here and let him speak a little bit
about what's going on oh great yeah
we're Charlie's houses Thanksgiving Day
I was actually supposed to be an Ambo
now am i setting up for the jump
Saturday
yesterday morning which was Wednesday we
were contacted by the Bureau of Land
Management Tomatoes office nothing
matters Rod Stewart here I was gonna say
he's got great hair fresh face you get
crazy eyes that location I don't want
him to die
you're so pleased no me neither I don't
him to die she's like a nice man you
know what I wanted to do let me go up
there and get slammed to there but be
fine so I won't get but be fine I want
to be like super cool I can knock that I
won't be yeah like it's so round yeah
it's like the worst concussion of all
time
I liked what you had to say about
Michael Bisping and how he shouldn't
have been allowed to because of course
Michael Bisping he's gonna want to fight
of course I thought it was very very I
thought I thought that you have to
protect a fighter from himself
especially a warrior like Bisbing that's
not you know that's on on the Commission
the UFC on the UFC not think you miss
yeah well thank itself I said the
Chinese Commission but the the the over
in China in it's too much get into on a
short thread or short subtext around
Instagram but the the governing body in
China and those foreign lands is the UFC
okay the little ones who sanctioned that
doesn't want to moderate and control
that yeah but it doesn't matter even if
it was in Las Vegas
wherever California Florida Brazil China
India to buy North Korea South Korea
where the [ __ ] it is yeah that to me it
should come down in the UFC being like
this isn't good man not good for you
even if for whatever any Commission even
if you pass these tests we just if we
don't know all the science behind we
know it can't be good
cuz no matter what you say you did get
concussed I mean she got dropped from a
left hook by Michael George at yeah and
he got choked unconscious
that's another concussion and then
you're fighting three weeks later I just
don't I think you gotta take care of
your own there and I get
you need money and you need a headliner
and you need to save the card grantees
on flight paths and nobody watched it no
one watched it at that time of day it
did it just and I know Michael Bisbee
wants to fight everyone's fight just
like the football player get knocked out
wants to play in the game yeah but there
are people who are smarter older
educated protecting your future to
protect your futures right that's right
is he retired is he gonna retire no he's
gonna do one more and his season I'm
signing a fight in England who that's
against our fight school that's a good
idea yeah for sure this was this was
silly I think I think it you know it
granted no one saw it so you know when I
post be like wait what happened like
yeah there you go that's what you don't
find on fight pass yeah so you don't
jump at the opportunity fight a young
wine like Kelvin Gastelum fight pass
terribly not and the other thing too you
know if Bisbee you know it could be
because he did have a long camp and
because he was concussed you know you
getting that striking war with when I
say more when you getting that striking
kind of contest contest with Kevin
Kelvin Gastelum you know in that punch
lands that's getting knocked out Bisping
whether he has the long camp or not sure
you know yeah Kelvin is a breath matchup
for me you have to also remember but I
take that out in kelvins a phenomenal
fighter the issue is the UFC living
Bisping fight and when he passed all the
tests really because last I checked we
we don't have any certainty test whether
your brains damage or not last time I
checked we don't have CT dentist slowly
don't there's no way to tell that and by
the way not not only did he get dropped
viciously he also got pounded when he
was back when he hit when he hit the
canvas gasoline jumped on oh yeah Gators
about three yeah yeah I mean I hated
seeing that [ __ ] yeah yeah I have this
new tip thing yeah I didn't read this
but I heard about it what isn't there
able to detect CT in a living player
excellent player confirmed this first
case of CT in living patient how'd they
detect it how do you honey read yet
researchers published what they say is
the first case living person identified
with degenerative brain disease chronic
traumatic
also in ICT the unnamed study by dr.
Bennett Fred McNeill how did they do it
it doesn't say a protein or something
that they okay it looked like just
depression in the brain huh
keeps going down yeah they don't say
yeah I just remember planning about this
it known from plaquing people with
Alzheimer's like symptoms such as I know
that CT how the [ __ ] did they detect it
I read about it and get back to it
that'd be great thanks might be great
yeah but within in bisby's case of
course gonna fire me was he's a grown
man he makes decisions that she
shouldn't have those decisions he
shouldn't have the ability to have the
decision he shouldn't be able to text
the boss of the company game I go on I
know a guy who step in find three weeks
and then you know Dana covers his ass
we're going you gotta get checked out
you just file a little bit but getting
checked that's not enough man no it's
absolutely not I got checked out I don't
care man you I saw you it can cuss it's
not gonna end well free listen let's not
do this I am amazed it was a brutal
fight for him with GSP that that was it
took a lot of punishment what about a
pond and because in that post I went his
case coaches the UFC and the Commission
should really be the ones who we hold
accountable for this one of his coaches
text me or DM me was like dude we told
him it we shouldn't do that but then
Bisbing goes with this one I'm doing it
cause the shot so then what do you do
you gotta give them prepared yeah hey
I'm sure that Bisbing is calling shots
he's not listening those coaches in when
it comes to fighting he's too
competitive but if your coaches go we're
not going with you man it's a terrible
idea to take years I feel like you have
a family we're not going with you
you think he still does it that's a good
question it yeah yeah draw a line in the
sand man you're right these are said
than done but so let's do something
great one percent what else you got you
all right so you guys are talking about
guns earlier
and this is kind of a four-part er so
this is really sad a woman was killed by
a deer hunter while she was walking her
dog team and I've been hunting - your
dog's gotta see the deer I don't
understand you don't shoot anyway one of
the things was I guess he was hunting
like past the curfew so that's one
reason that's what I read other in other
places but I don't know bro I've been
I've hunted enough to know that you have
to see the deer because the reason you
look at the deer is you shoot it
specifically in a specific place that
looks like Frank Mir if you made hold on
it really does it's so terrible it's a
terrible story that should not be
laughing at this but he does look like
for me no but you but by the way again
you have to see the [ __ ] deer so you
know where you're gonna shoot it use two
hundred yards away from it yeah he made
a mistake I mean he immediately called
9-1-1 she's a good guy it's a terrible
scene cooperated with authorities he's
not been charged with a crime
how would you discipline a guy like that
Yuki it's it's a terrible accident it's
a terrible [ __ ] act I probably you
know he'll punish himself after I give
them a year for that goatee that would
be for shooting this a woman yeah yeah
do a little time yeah I don't know I
guess it's I think I don't mistake
though I think he'll do at his own time
and he's on my for life yeah I mean you
feel so terrible metaphor you go in life
dude look at us let's write a book yeah
that sucks
it's extra bummer he's definitely having
a hard time ah yeah of course yeah dude
you got a look you got to see this yeah
looking but yeah that's all so it does
make me mad I have to be honest we know
so many hunts it makes me angry because
I would never do that I would never
I don't know anybody could be you know
it is it's so stupid it's so [ __ ]
stupid
you see the [ __ ] deer and you don't
shoot at rustling leaves and the reason
you have to see the deer so that you
know to shoot it right behind the
shoulder if you're deer crazy you want
to drop that deer you don't want to
[ __ ] wing it because it'll run away
yeah the fellow hotter myself if you're
deer hungry I'll shootin that's the
problem you know the deep end I just got
to get my shot off but [ __ ] that III
have a
problem with it as I think about it
because yep I don't understand how you
would do that what did he see the dog
look like hold on but is she walking her
dog in deer hunting territory yes always
on the hunter it's always I know I know
it's hear me out there she was walking
her dog in her around the property area
but I guess you're allowed to to a hunt
in that area yeah and it's deer hunt in
the area yes it's in New York somewhere
yeah
she's walking at night that's the thing
so I don't know they're not allowed to
hunt a night at a certain time they're
not allowed see that's where I read
somewhere hunting rifle will travel that
bullet he was on his pistol pistol too
and yards away with a [ __ ] pistol I
think we first bought a put him in the
military as a sniper yeah I still cuz
you gonna be it's quite an email you
could hunt with a pistol deer deer
I didn't know you could you hit a kill a
deer from two and yards away with a
pistol that's that's already even bets
is that not a little impressive yeah
that's weird
a pistol got a [ __ ] pistol it's gonna
be investigated thoroughly so who knows
what happened here now I'm trying to
turn chicken [ __ ] in the chicken soup
here yeah guy can awfully shoot from far
away yeah
military I have you serving your country
I'm usually not cynical but I have to
say you know there's also a chance he's
a psycho and wanted to kill somebody and
said oh I thought it was a deer and I
would investigate that his goatee would
match that profile yeah
you know I I'd say he might in my foreal
at my event thrill kill why are you
shooting it I have a lot of questions I
got a lot of questions I'm very
skeptical
so even yours it's close to Buffalo I'm
gonna be up there what if I get shot the
deer
I look like a deer you do I look like a
little dove don't wear antlers well it's
around I don't know and I'm looking at
you're a big reindeer hat I'm looking a
little thick yeah it looked like a big
old buck what are you weighing right now
what do you think and don't tell me you
don't step on scales at me I don't have
a scale have scales give me he said you
don't know what's up on scale all the
time yeah you have scale yeah why would
you yeah I always [ __ ] you a scale MJ
168 once you're Skelton I do but I mean
is it
I haven't used your skill you have you
have to when you step on girls
I'd say Utah Utah's got some big big
kids big boys its Mullins well I
a lot of Samoans so to the best looking
people I probably ever seen in my life
have neva in a brother/sister they're
half Tongan and half white and I looked
at them when they're in the [ __ ]
thing and they were with a Samoan and I
went I go you two of the best looking
people you a couple have children
immediately and they go no we're brother
and sister uh-huh
oh my good you tall we still upset okay
they say that was I should have been
like how boy I was so [ __ ] right they
were so I was like you're like any or
they thick like they were not think they
were just letting eautifully athletic
and muscular they were like how do you
have a picture of them I don't know I
don't give a [ __ ] alright cuz I figure
you have Tongans yeah so does a picture
half-time nudes is the kids the dude
well if you're working with a piece I
can always marvel at it alright you can
send that oh what else you got you so
there's a couple of more stories about
this another hunter shot a pickup truck
that he thought was a deer all right
around the same what kind of pickup
truck was it the round pickup truck
that's always what year oh well you've
seen some of those other ones I can see
I can confuse a metal yeah object was
heaving at 40 miles an hour as a dish
was they be no trip covered in fur did
it have hose and a black soft nose no
well then what the [ __ ] are you doing
let me ask you something once last time
you saw a buck running down the road
playing [ __ ] wheeler Walker junior
out the side of its ear I highly doubt
the deer had a radio on what the [ __ ]
that's why it's called drunk as [ __ ]
dudes it's called drinking this is some
redneck [ __ ] yeah oh look man I'll tell
you something I know guys for a fact I
knew him when I was younger so don't
judge me I know for a fact they would be
deer hunting and a big old plane would
fly by maybe I did the [ __ ] plane yes
that happens what a bunch for Didion's
that happens in West Virginia shot at
the plane will be the hills as eyes
takes place yeah that's
broum movie mmm hell people the hills
reading a good book called hillbilly
Ehlinger right now I recommend when they
shoot at the plane nothing ever landed
the point it's very very it's also very
stupid yeah flicked up the people in
Texas that was in Florida shooting at
the hurricane you don't have to put out
a warning to tell people stop using your
guns and firing at the hurricane Oh Mike
take a kicky kicky don't work hey it's
not working
can you imagine watching in Houston
neighbors like bring it on well my guns
got my shield yeah you know the new set
to issue a warning please do not shoot
into the hurricane it doesn't do
anything out of countries like in the
Middle East I'll tell you not to shoot
in the air like an IROC they used to
shoot in the air a lot it's a
celebration the air the bullets come
[ __ ] back down and hit people but
they're like kill people they certainly
do they set them up and put them down
there all the way up and they come all
the way down as a piece of leg is this
is a true story that if you throw a
penny off the Empire State Building hit
someone I kill them I would imagine I
don't know do we know if that's true
story
if you throw a penny off the Empire
State Building to kill I think they'd
try that on Mythbusters or something in
their force and then you couldn't yeah
shout the Mythbusters you know I'm miss
Mythbusters alumni and broke all the
records I didn't think a human being
could do it I shot her in the dick yes
and it was yeah very homeowner shooting
us in the dick
yeah SWAT guys right you got a squid
shoot us then take out it I don't know
what to tell you man I don't mean to is
this the real well Mythbusters did it
and they said it couldn't kill you son
but what's it can't know we put in a
[ __ ] you up right it's gonna hurt like a
mug it was part of the ground like a
leaf it strike you small flick from the
forehead
cushioned by hair very hard wow really
yeah like a leaf no one said it would
flutter like a leaf to the ground but if
I take a quarter and flick the [ __ ] at
it from the top of this building
he's a face he's gotta have some you're
right ow a bullet a bullet a heavy
bullet is gonna go through your [ __ ]
head the bolts aren't heavy huh you I am
this is myth boats aren't heavy at all I
mean if you shoot up I know this for a
fact I don't want cut if you shoot up it
loses all its power and this goes first
of all I go like this like Looney Tunes
flail they do kill me no they tell you
never shoot in the air
we in trouble for shoot entire no one
killed no and you know what the military
do they just fire in the air yeah like
this somebody that's gonna hit us with
that tell us the truth they're probably
people who know this oh no no no we
don't need any fact check I know for a
fact you don't dive in shoot a balloon
no I think you do check out check that
out look that up because I'm standing
about my guns at it's very release yeah
yeah but throwing a penny off the Empire
State but which is higher no it's a
higher I don't think it is then fired a
gun in the sky no it's a good question
too
so guest you with some bro sides I think
yes the most positive if you shoot a get
in the air
and if I'm a miss legends and terminal
velocity okay a falling bullet ah this
is a completely new edition article okay
so I'm sorry gunfire occurs when people
with guns use them to mark an event it's
culturally accepted fire protection I
was not only fireworks but sometimes
bullets in the air on holidays in
Afghanistan Pakistan northern India and
many places in Latin America
gunfire rings out above the noise of
fireworks in the streets in Barcelona
when FC edged out Real Madrid blah blah
blah a little go be a bullet fired into
the air can return to Earth at speeds
between 300 700 feet per second fast
enough the purse appears a person's
skull yeah this was not an isolated
incident
it wounded hundreds and killed dozens in
recent years in the u.s. oh here we go
deaths like these are reported
investigate every year a young man in
Fresno California was killed when a
friend's vertical lucky shot went
straight up and came straight back down
entering a skull a randomly fired bullet
hit a police helicopter in Riverside
California striking the pilot in the
foot forced to make an emergency landing
here Dallas Texas January 1st on 12 a
bullet came through the roof of a
bedroom where a woman was nursing her
baby landed next to her on her bed right
through our roof yeah because I bullets
much heavier and then the pennies flat
so the air picks up all that area yeah
well it's way heavier so don't shoot
bullets in the air kids I know a lot
about ballistics
[ __ ] you shushing that's good good good
good that's a bunch of bullets yeah I'll
get inside get inside
like y'all yeah cuz in a minute it's
gonna fall to the ground so that's why I
always wear a very heavy helmet me too
and shoulders deal there's just two
quick ones just about that deer hunting
accident stuff so another dude shot
himself in the leg accidentally this off
it all happened within a week span yep
man yeah what's found this one might be
a suicide he was found dead in his tree
stand with a bullet hole to his head
probably but it could have been an
accident so they're gonna investigate it
damage exile himself in the face people
go oh you guys my tree Stan I'm glass in
the field and this is my opportunity to
shoot somebody anonymous no way no sure
there are people who are psychos psychos
hunt sent to psychopath found everywhere
yeah thrill killers like - you know -
yeah they got a hive got a gun they're
frustrated they haven't seen a deer and
they're like I hate people that guy shot
and scared my dear you know what he's
got to go so that's like that uh that
football player who was in the NFL Pat
Tillman you know about this habit play
the Arizona State fan off football
player captain safety for Arizona
Cardinals was like you know what I'm
gonna be a special-forces dude
military during the Rangers died by
friendly fire correctly originates it it
was the enemies you know whoever alqaeda
killed him then found out is friendly
fire and then some of the conspiracy
think that a lot of the guys in that
were jealous of them because you just
went right to the top you know there's
some weird [ __ ] going on there was some
weird [ __ ] yeah it's a bummer for sure I
don't know all the details but it's very
scary very scary high-powered rifles
really that can go a long way you're
talking about guns you if you're a twin
mag 300 the kind of gun that I was using
that's what snipers use in the military
so you can shoot somebody if you're
really good if you're like a SEAL team
sniper sniper Scout you know whatever
you are those guys can hit you with a
heavy enough bullet with a wooden mag
300 they can hit you from a field 200
eight football fields will I mean crazy
they can hit you from 800 meters a
thousand meters skilled for crazy yeah
that should I will move on from that so
in LA someone stole well a team I'm sure
stole two hundred seventy thousand
dollars worth of vodka what are you
gonna do with it I guess that's 9
thousand bottles but I'll sell on the
black market we it's hard to hide that's
a lot of [ __ ] to shell out yeah who
wants some vodka you go to the nightclub
like no let's man off we spoke from
trial service I got a deal for you I got
a deal so says the types name is
surveillance footage at the shows three
men behind a razor wire fence one climbs
the fence knocks the camera over before
they break in yeah no [ __ ] I I when I
was in college my friend was a bit of a
criminal he stole a bunch of wine from
the basement of a restaurant like he was
a bad guy look a bunch of bottles for me
say a bunch like what I was probably
maybe I think I was old Arthur probably
25 and he had done it I remember I went
to his house lived on a farm and he had
like he's like these bottles are super
expensive we drank and then why I was
just okay
it's like I don't know if this is so
expensive but good job on robbing a
[ __ ] you know only 20 bottles though
you know somebody yes those friends that
just have [ __ ] you're like what what's
that what are those bars a call it's
doing in the under there and was that
the first up over there he's just a just
hanging out no don't nothing to see over
here with us kitchen
alright a girl accidentally killed
herself well accidentally died from
falling out of window trying to take a
selfie and she's been traveling the
world documenting her stuff on and so 24
years old it's just hot - yeah
where did she she's from New Zealand but
she she was in the UK when she fell out
of a window gosh taking a picture of
what just like her hanging out on the
window
yeah I'm fell it was like although
people this happens a lot she's [ __ ]
gorgeous yeah she's a smoke show that is
a real shame yeah well don't post that
one did you see a bummer man yeah do you
see the I think there's a Chinese person
taking a selfie on a Segway and just
right over the edge of oh no yeah no
sign make sure you guys did you know
they do this yeah yeah yeah game over
you got a look at where you're going man
do I when I was push my kid through
since she finally takes a nap you know
this mean you don't any when we grew up
this dorkus Mallorca every bit of 50 is
Texan and runs into the thing right for
right now I think like oh my god give
the old stiff Akane I almost died that
wrong oh my battling come on yeah come
on man look up you're missing the
[ __ ] world first of all y'all so 50
what do you playing Ellie's phone candy
crush I almost [ __ ] that about how
much happened to me when I it was walked
in trash yes yes yes yes take it second
type thinking about it I'm an [ __ ] I
was in Seattle walking I stepped off and
the valence almost ran over my I almost
died yes I do and I'll sock you to Brian
over yet baby ah suck God that would
have sucked so bad I don't know if you
to kill me but Daffy
that car was going very fast it was a
man I think he would have been dead
you think yes I do it was a truck or you
two stole my abilities I would have
stopped by the way I don't you bet I
went I went it was a car was a man it
was a truck I don't even know what it
was I just I really I don't like holy
[ __ ] I we saw it I almost died you
almost died we started laughs you almost
[ __ ] died what's up guys do it just
laugh almost died oh my buddy my buddy
happened to him he almost got hit by
literally it like he could feel the wind
right and he goes poof he's a it was so
close and this one was like oh she
screamed and he was like I just almost
died yes how he the car same thing karma
said I came so close to him like it came
he felt the wind in Alma it touch like
his shoe he was like oh my god and he he
ended up going to the bathroom and he
fainted always yeah he had reflective
Zolo
like he fainted any other death stories
chin one more so it's on a half call you
the groomer cut my dropping happy no you
do that some lady was on the freeway ran
out of gas
pulled over the side and then she
started walk into the gas station and a
homeless guy told her go back in your
car lock your doors I'll get the gas for
you so apparently according to the story
he gave his last $20 to buy her gas and
then she was saved now she did have
GoFundMe thing and it has since raised
like with this report when it first came
out it was like sixty five thousand
seventy thousand from now it's at three
hundred and sixty-five thousand dollars
in donations oh my god he wasn't you
didn't give this hopeless man $35,000
who's that girl he seems like he's he's
good though like he was like does he
know now look at him now if you give a
homeless guy 306 five let's go from zero
306 I know he's gonna go thanks math
near you you know you're right about
that he was I guess he was a firefighter
and like a military vet from what she
says so
but also psychologically you think he's
okay - after his $65,000 or do you think
it's smarter maybe set him up with a
bank count you transfer money in there
every month pretty sure they'll do
something like that though also I'd
probably
bro but I wet my beak a little bit I
mean it's raising its racing surprise
oh me too bro you know man I can't man
we can't believe me through and c-5 out
yeah there's a lot now it was my idea so
you realize you only get a hundred care
that you crazy and you're gonna shoot
that hurricane to your van for your own
good for younger your own because what I
can't do is transfer 65 you become the
Punisher I thought we can't have yep
you ready for my dropping knowledge I
think so I'm never that ready for it
well this is interesting because it
gives you an idea of how when you're
distracted why you shouldn't be on
texting on your phone oh boy as an
example so let me just read you a real
quick thing the whole was that happy if
they'll real quick I know he looks
amazing he does like real friends yeah
he does he looks like a sweetheart get
away from my car because look from it's
also guys on reals he's 19 years old 17
you know he looked real friendly don't
[ __ ] touch me but no he looks really
nice yeah they way from my neighborhood
it keeps birds in his beard alright uh
and we can look this looks like this
video we can actually look of it imagine
you are asked to watch a short video in
which six people three in white shirts
and three in black shirts pass
basketballs around while you watch you
must keep a silent count of the number
of passes made by the people in white
shirts so I gotta do at some point a
gorilla strolls into the middle of the
action faces the camera and thumps his
chest and then leaves spending nine
seconds on screen would you see the
gorilla
alright now they did this experiment
with ten thousand people let me get this
straight B so I'm calculating how many
people in white shirts are passing the
ball yeah how you keep track of that
just the white shirts then they're
gorillas to basketball odds my vision
the gorilla comes into the middle and we
can watch this dude he block the vision
um well I can still see the basketball
team pass now if my mission is right
here watch this fly missions that count
the balls like you want
so before you don't look at anything but
before you just watch this for a second
Simonson's a person to pretend this all
happened in 1999 the long time would
count how many times the players wearing
white past the basketball
- great just more confusing four five
six seven eight nine ten and eleven
twelve thirteen fourteen fifteen how
many passes did you fifteen clearly did
you see the gorilla rect answer is 15
passes good these [ __ ] testimony the
girls yeah it's all the groups are
alright easily yeah
you know how yeah how many people didn't
see the gorilla up tall of 10,000 people
how many well documented by the way
that's stupid-ass gorilla almost 50
percent what's wrong with people because
they're a get along like us they're
there they're looking at they're looking
only at the white people passing the
ball and it's very easy to that's it
miss very important information
especially if you come from certain
cultures where you're focused on to
focus on one thing as opposed to the
relationship between things was it the
silliest [ __ ] test of all time yeah
but it's really [ __ ] right but it's
amazing at Harvard Harvard University
Wow people miss the grill half the
people who watch the video and count the
passes missed the gorillas it was as
though the gorilla was invisible not
only did I see the gorilla but I was
critiquing their shitty Caucasian path
yes doesn't matter yeah I also mentioned
grown to you you also knew that there is
a gorilla and remember I said that mean
even if you did it you would you miss
everything
you wouldn't say and you're another
stupid tell the story 1999 no this was
done really they redid it again Harvard
very recently this experiment reveals
two things that we are missing a lot of
what goes on around us and that we have
no idea that we are MIT what we are
missing kids at the top they're doing
the same [ __ ] tomorrow to our surprise
is not on the best-known experiments in
psychology it is described in most
introductory textbooks and features in
more than a dozen science museums it has
been used by everyone from preachers and
teachers to corporate trainers and
terrors like this will not be telling me
times 1 2 3 4
five I terrible Basking six terrible
passing skills seven eight nine ten
grill in the scene but you can see how
you'd miss it because it's it's mixes in
I I don't see how you missed that by the
way no he didn't open the grill I
thought the girl is part of it like I
knew over and over you missed a gorilla
over and over
so that's crazy yeah yeah there you go
Texas and driving they say to look down
at a text if you're in a car I forget
how much I think if you're going 40
miles an hour would you close your eyes
and drive the length of a football field
it's the same [ __ ] you know I'm saying
yeah yeah it's all you and that's why
when you think you can do one thing and
drive you know you can't somebody else I
don't know one person that takes it that
everybody does it everyone - it's a real
real problem it's a problem it's a
problem it's probably real problem I'll
tell you what's not a problem that
December 7 8 & 9 December 7 8 9 I'm at
Cobbs oh that's not a problem at all get
your [ __ ] tickets cuz if you think
that black guerrilla was talented yeah
if you think those three white girls
passing that basketball were talented
killing much so I say what else is a
problem though what I'm doing that I got
a shoot Goldbergs all Thursday flight it
Friday then I got a yeah morning and
then I fly back Friday to shoot and fly
back this is the short flight though
yeah super short flight yeah it still
suck there's one way to yeah that
definitely sucks you figured out though
that's not [ __ ] you I never said that
you're you're mr. characterizing me all
services donate sales can find a crane
on me and come on I've never said that
what oh I'm a German goo-goo-goo come
bust on my face I'm right now I'm
warning you bro you pushing me too far
on a Monday don't do it again I can only
be pushed so far see I don't push you
too far
I don't put it's better it's bad let's
see Brian yeah go see me this third time
you push that far see alright man I'm
with you bro
I don't want push you too far I'm
warning you I don't want push you in the
sucking dick and Sam says hey I told you
about oh yeah I'm not pushing you gotta
be careful now
oh my god wait thank you from my mouth
it's called I don't know what's your now
I'm sorry bro you're not gonna suck
anyone's dick and Sam friends right now
I'm gonna get physical with you through
it again okay I don't want to get
physical
thank you Mike dates yeah you can do it
it's Thursday I'm an Ontario improv
Inland Empire 20 seconds left with 20
tickets left
well wrote and then today at noon by the
time this comes out oh my god I'm at the
Wilbur theater in Boston January 19th
the Friday before UFC 220 which is gonna
be Cain Velasquez versety pay I'm there
the night before at the Wilbur theater
for godsakes biggest show I've ever done
it's huge gee fat kid calm for tickets
Boston Wilbur theater and if you sell
that out I want to say one thing
yeah but who the [ __ ] do you think you
are I know I'm nervous bro if you sell
that out who the [ __ ] do you think you
are cuz this road pump is gonna get I'm
gonna come at you yeah wait am I the
road pup or your the road bub well you
said this for the road pop oh another
year ah my Road dog your road toll road
dog towed and now I think Ronnie pace or
respect cuz I'm Road tree frog he wrote
toads I'm Road kafra I'm I'm just we
have to Kate I want to keep track of the
[ __ ] Wilbur theater tickets now
because then because I'm flip out on air
if it's official who do you think you
are it's called - who do you think you
are show that's to be the
my first best for everyone who do you
think you are great it's a lair who do
you think you are
yeah let's take it's gonna say I'm super
nervous about Wilbur theater Boston TV a
calm but before all that that's just a
huge announcer before all that on the
13th I'm in Syracuse New York December
14 15 16 them in Buffalo New York
yeah and I'm eating wings I can't
promise I won't have buffalo wing sauce
all over my hands yeah you will so don't
so don't touch helium comment about your
eyes good stuff
tak calm so Ontario improv this Thursday
13th Syracuse fourteen fifteen
sixteenths Buffalo and then January 16th
or nineteen sorry June 19th Boston
Wilbur it's on go see Brian account this
weekend and compliment Thank You Utah I
loved you guys at wise guys yeah why
it's rights white why it's rock my
washer twice twice with a sprinkling of
Samoan Lehigh white white white white
white white tea fat cake on for all the
tickets are Brian and myself also
tonight the big brown teas drop and the
fine kid dick diver teas are back saw
some of those being worn in my show and
you take divers oh yeah oh we got dick
divers all over brother I love it I'm
excited see fat cake Amrit released at
5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight big brown
breakdown heavy weight podcast in Irish
tea and the dick diver is back T back a
docked on this the fire to write a suck
you off we're out